A tense day in Jerusalem as
thousands of Israeli nationalists
marched through the streets
in a provocative annual flag parade.
Far right.
National Security Minister
Itamar Ben Javier
joined the crowds just a few hours ago.
You can see him there.
He's been convicted of supporting
anti-Palestinian terrorism,
but was greeted here
like a rock star
with some marchers
chanting, the prime minister is here.
While the march was mostly peaceful,
but some demonstrators
threw rocks at journalists
including two of our own.
They also taunted journalists in hijabs,
some shouting, May your village burn.
Two people have been arrested
The annual march celebrates
Israel's capture of East Jerusalem
during the 1967 war.
Israel later annexed the territory
in a move
not recognized under international law.
Let's bring in our CNN
head of skull to his live in Jerusalem.
Husband
today had us clearly a day of tension
in Jerusalem.
Tell us what you have been
seeing, witnessing
in the last few hours
and the type of people
who've been turning out for this rally.
Yeah, Cristina,
this day is called Jerusalem Day.
As you noted, as the day
when Israeli celebrate Israel capturing
control of East Jerusalem in the 1967
war captured control
from Jordan
and for Israelis
it's a celebration
they see it as unifying
their their capital unifying
Jerusalem until 1967 Jews can go to the
holiest sites
in the old city of Jerusalem
which lies in East Jerusalem.
But for Palestinians who want the east
we want East Jerusalem
as the capital of their future state.
They see this day
is incredibly provocative
especially because in the last few years
it's essentially become a right
wing nationalistic rally.
Most of the people who attend this day
tend to be definitely from the right wing
many from the religious Zionist,
many from
settlers from the occupied West Bank.
And there typically does tend to be
some sort of scuffles and violence
and that's what we saw today.
Not only
a very heavy hand from the police
that had deployed
thousands of police officers
to try to keep the calm in some way,
but also today towards reporters.
We were standing
in the cordoned off area
that the police had set up for reporters
overlooking the Damascus Gate area,
which is one of the main entrances
to the Muslim quarter.
Of the Old City.
This is one of the paths
that the marchers went on.
And we started to not only get taunts
from the marchers, especially towards
some of our Palestinian
journalist colleagues, things
like May Your Village Burn. We also heard
marchers chanting
things
about getting revenge on Palestine
or raising their names.
But also at one point
they started throwing things at us
rocks, bottles, cans.
I saw at least two journalists
get injured.
Many people had to take cover
put on helmets and the like.
The Israeli police did say
they ended up arresting
at least two people
and they're investigating more.
But again,
to show you
that the antagonism wasn't just towards
the Palestinians in the area,
but it was also towards us journalists.
But other than those events,
it was largely peaceful.
And I should say most of the marchers
there were there just to march
and dance and dance
around with their flags.
And it didn't get to the same level,
of course, that we saw in 20, 21.
We were there
covering the same march in 2021,
and that was when Hamas,
the militant group
that runs Gaza, had threatened that
if the march was not canceled
then they would respond
and they did respond with rockets
towards Jerusalem.
Sirens went off
as the marchers were on the route,
and I actually canceled
the march as a result.
And that of course set off
that 11 day war
between the Israeli military
and the militants in Gaza.
Now while the militant groups in Gaza
had threatened
what they called some sort of response
if unnamed red lines were crossed.
So far
we haven't seen any sort
of major response
either from Gaza
or elsewhere as a result.
But, you know,
we could see something later on,
but there was little expectation
that there would be a similar response
as we saw in 20, 21.
And how much
emphasis is being put
on the fact
of the timing of this march
this time around us?
I mean, this comes five days
after a cease
fire was reached
between Israel and Islamic Jihad.
What is the situation there now?
You're saying
that the threat of major escalation
is unlikely I mean, is that concern now
disappearing as night falls
there as the march concludes?
Yeah, well, in terms of timing,
this is always
held on the same day,
which is on the
according to the Hebrew calendar
when this
when Israel captured
East Jerusalem in 1967.
But it is happening,
as you know just a few days
after a cease fire was reached
between Islamic
Jihad militants and the Israeli military
after that
several day long conflict there.
And in a way
I actually think
that probably helped cool the situation.
Having a cease fire
a few days before helped cool
the situation on the ground
because of course
if the if the conflict was ongoing
with the militants
in Gaza
and the Israeli military
while this march was going on,
I think we could have definitely expected
some sort of
major response
from the militants
there towards Jerusalem.
Towards this march.
But that was a major focus
and a major push
by those who were trying to get
that cease
fire, by the Egyptians, by others,
knowing that this date was
was coming very quickly.
They wanted that ceasefire done before
today's march Kristie.
All right.
Had us
go to appreciate your reporting there
live from Jerusalem tonight.
Thank you.
Well, Palestinians in Gaza are rallying
against the holding of this parade
in Jerusalem at the border with Israel.
These were the scenes earlier.
Palestinians see the march
as a provocation, as had us was saying,
and a threat.
And in previous years, it has led
to clashes.